au cours de la dernière décennie l'ère
du numérique a permis au discours
conspirationniste de sortir de l'ombre
ce qui a suscité chez certains d'entre
nous un mélange d'incrédulité de
curiosité voire de fascinations et si à
travers le prisme de l'humour que
plusieurs sites web pages facebook
chaîne Youtube et balado ont choisi
d'observer et d'analyser ces univers
parallèles
Jeff les mouvements conspirationnistes
que tu observes attentivement depuis
bien des années ben on le sait au
dépense ça se faisait un peu plus en
vase clone dans des univers un peu plus
parallèles et là de plus en plus est
devenu permettez-moi l'anglais séisme
mainstream dans l'oeil du grand public
j'ai quand même l'impression que
certaines fascinations qui se
développaient des gens qui se sont mis
observés ça tourner ça en spectacle
qu'on commande dont on rit qu'est-ce que
tu en penses comme tu dis ça fait
maintenant huit ans
sur le web et avec la pandémie ben on a
raison s'inquiéter qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont été séduits par ces
théories là qui commence à adhérer ces
mouvements là mais à l'inverse ça
exposait beaucoup de gens qui n'étaient
peut-être pas au courant de des
mouvements complotistes et ça crée à
l'inverse des gens qui sont complètement
obsédés par les complotistes mais qui ne
sont pas complexes même ça devient en
quelque sorte comme tu dis un spectacle
donc on voit dans les réseaux ici au
Québec mais aussi ailleurs des gens dans
le passe-temps c'est de suivre à la
trace des compétits qui parlent à qui
qui est en chican avec qui un peu comme
une télé-réalité quasiment ça devient
oui souvent très humoristique ça tourne
à la dérision et à la moquerie de ces
gens-là en même temps est-ce qu'il y a
autant de décision c'est une bonne chose
ça a lieu de se poser la question ça
pose effectivement des questions tout à
fait légitimes on pourrait parler de
mille et un exemple de ce type de
personne ou de groupes de personnes
parlons d'un exemple en particulier
peut-être davantage connu dans le monde
anglo-saxon qui en ont
c'est un balado un podcast américain
parti par une gangs qui ont commencé à
suivre qui ont atteindre le dans les
débuts trouvaient que c'était une idée
un peu ridicule qui anal et on
commençait à suivre qu'est-ce qui est
arrivé dans le mouvement c'est qui qui
sont les têtes d'affiche qu'est-ce qu'il
raconte cette semaine et on fait un
balado hebdomadaire là-dessus au fil du
temps sont devenus des experts en
question en suivant ça de manière
amateur un peu artistique ben ils ont
développé des réels connaissances de ce
mouvement-là et puis là on le voit ça
gagne un popularité au point où même ils
viennent ici au Canada à Toronto font ça
le comble quand ils font un
enregistrement de balado en direct et
c'est justement là que je vais déjà
faire
[Musique]
et c'est parti pour toi un petit vol une
petite heure
[Musique]
fin d'après-midi à Toronto maintenant
que le soir tombe tranquillement on va
justement rencontrer Dieu une field du
podcast du balado qui en a un an et demi
après leur tournée à travers l'Amérique
du Nord en partant du chaud soleil de la
Californie un petit tour par Brooklyn
ils sont maintenant à Toronto j'ai bien
hâte de lui parler on y va
Julien field bonjour bonjour bienvenue
dans notre univers à nous décrypteurs on
était très heureux que vous acceptiez
notre invitation comment vous expliquer
l'intérêt l'engouement pour vos podcasts
je crois que très souvent des gens qui
nous écoutent connaissent quelqu'un ou
connaisse une personne dans leur famille
qui passe par ce genre de choses après
il y a aussi une partie de l'audience je
crois qui utilise ça comme un
profilactique pour pouvoir
explorer les théories du complot sans y
tomber
vous retournez Chicago puis ensuite
Minneapolis dans une tournée qui dont le
titre fait référence au reptilien c'est
ça expliquez-nous un peu en fait
on fait un spectacle qui est sur le
thème des reptiliens c'est à dire
pourquoi les gens
et c'est 4% des États-Unis pensent que
des reptiliens contrôlent le
gouvernement et le pouvoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si on veut que les gens comprennent
quelque chose on peut pas juste leur
servir sans la garniture si on leur sert
quelque chose sans sel sans sucre ça ils
vont pas vouloir le manger les gens
parlent de nous pas nécessairement comme
un spectacle c'est à dire qu'on n'est
pas en train de rendre fantastique ou
plus cartoonesque ce qu'on étudie on
étudie quelque chose qui est déjà
fantastique et cartoonesque
on s'occupe quand même bien sûr de ne
pas promouvoir et plateformer les gens
qui ont créé et qui profitent de cette
théorie du complot mais qui peut quand
même adresser le fait que ces théories
du complot existent les gens y croient
et c'est pas des gens qui ne sont pas
humains c'est nos c'est nos voisins
c'est nos parents c'est nos frères et
soeurs si on les déshumanise il y a pas
de d'espoir de garder
le côté social le côté où les gens
restent une culture et et peuvent
s'appuyer l'un sur l'autre donc ne pas
stratiser ces personnes essayer de faire
comprendre les mécanismes derrière la
désinformation et le fait qu'on tombe
dedans et mais aussi avec une touche
d'humour et c'est là où votre travail
subtil de rire de tout sans se moquer
des personnes qui l’incarnent c'est un
peu ça oui c'est un peu ça je crois que
c'est parce que
on peut faire des choses que les
journalistes ne peuvent pas donc les
journalistes font partie de l'écosystème
de nos pensées et on est constamment en
train de s'appuyer sur des sources
journalistiques mais on peut dire le
truc qu'on aimerait que le journaliste
dise mais qu'il a pas le droit de dire
un exemple
des blagues
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez
en parlant de qui on a un parlant de
toute théorie du complot que vous
abordez dans vos dans votre podcast
est-ce que vous avez eu du une
rétroaction un feedback parfois négatif
de ces personnes de ces univers est-ce
qu'on s'en prend à vous des gens qui
pourraient mal comprendre votre objectif
et votre démarche je crois que c'est là
où on a une position quand même assez
particulière c'est à dire oui bien sûr
on reçoit plein de messages négatifs et
positif donc comme tout média qui aurait
une plateforme disons mais je crois que
les gens ne nous voient pas comme un
ennemi qui se bat contre dans deux camps
séparés on préférerait un peu incarner
une approche où on ne nie pas que la
méfiance est très utile et même valide
mais quand même temps il y a des choses
qui sont juste pas vrai il y a des
choses qui sont des manipulations
[Applaudissements]
en terminant il y a des gens qui vous
écoutent qui nous écoutent qui écoutent
notre conversation et qui comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure un oncle faire une
sœur une mère qui est basculée dans cet
univers là si vous aviez un conseil à
donner à ces personnes un seul quel
serait-il ou deux je dirais patience
déjà c'est très très difficile parce que
c'est une connexion humaine et on a
l'impression de perdre la personne
c'est-à-dire de perdre contact avec les
personnes ça peut revenir
mais c'est difficile je dirais il y a
pas de réponse facile à cette situation
sauf
l'empathie l'empathie est aussi s'il y a
des manières gentilles de rediriger les
gens en dehors des écrans en dehors de
passer des heures sur Youtube en dehors
de ce céder même avec la télé les news à
la télé passer plus de temps dehors de
passer plus de temps à avoir des moments
d'interaction qui existent on a des
choses qui
qui ont de la profondeur dans notre vie
des relations que la profondeur et on
s'intéresse moins à ça c'est naturel
mais solution magique je sais pas mais
en tout cas une de ces solutions c'est
d'écouter votre podcast je dirais jamais
ça mais si vous le dites si
vous le dites merci infiniment merci à
vous